buongiorno intro alternativa
direttamente a letto perché tanto
youtube non è la televisione ho deciso
di fare l'anno superchallenge sfida che
prevede la non assunzione di zucche
l'aggiunta di qualsiasi tipo per una
settimana non ho ben chiaro quali siano
tutti gli alimenti qui lista per andarli
a controllare ma la cosa meravigliosa
sarà a chiamare a breve gli altri
ragazzi per informarli che la faranno
insieme a me il crudele comincia a
essere in italia
allora qui c'è una lista che è mia ma
che mi hanno richiamato il tradimento
che sono concesso appena no enrico sei
tu che c'è una connessione di me poi
eccolo tempo un altro che c'è una bella
commissione vedo dio per una settimana
non mangeremo zucchero posso fare la
domanda si sa che il canale
voglio fare un passo di lato la linea è
giusto fare tutto insieme quest'ultimo
anno e mezzo è stato meraviglioso
vi faccio una lista di tutte le cose che
non potete mangiare non potete mangiare
nessun tipo di zucchero pane bianco ebay
con i cookies i prezzi quelle cose lì
solo potete mangiare integrale non
potete mangiare condimenti l'aceto
balsamico eric è bello vederti al
contrario comunque come degli stralli ma
non è che ha il telefono al contrario
adesso sei dritto enrico possiamo andare
avanti
banane e patate ma le patate le bevande
gassate zuccherate e alcol
ragazzi non possiamo dargli alla batta
non possiamo bere alcol
possiamo mangiare banane non possiamo
bere alcol non possiamo magnate questo è
un operaio
limitare il consumo di stevia ciliegie
uva mango ananas prugne e anguria il
cioccolato fondente all 85 per cento
yogurt e formaggi da limitare nel caso
tuo la linea che sei intollerante la
soia la puoi prendere ma non zuccherata
volete sapere cosa potete mangiare tutta
la carne tutto il pesce avvocato
broccoli cavoletti di bruxelles la
lattuga di cipolle gli spinaci tutte
queste cose qui
mele albicocche arance pesche tipiche di
questa stagione semi e noci legumi e
fagioli tutte le spezie acqua
blatter non zuccherato quindi questi
dati alternativi forse soglia non si può
[Risate]
olio tipo di olive cocco avvocato infine
uova il burro e raffinata ma gli tolgono
lavorare una porzione di niente cosa c'è
là dentro scelto solito whisky in una
volta che è l'altra e questo è tutto
ragazzi ciao tutto il lupo ciao ciao
ciao
ed è così che inizia forse una delle
avventure di cui mi pentii di più in
assoluto nella mia vita però stamattina
mi sono pesato i ragazzi non è che
andasse molto bene ogni volta che mi
hanno detto che assomiglio a jack black
capisco che magari mi sto rilassando un
po troppo mettiamola così cercherò di
mettermi sotto vediamo che cosa succede
agli altri e non oso nemmeno immaginare
cosa faranno
non voglio nemmeno saperlo iniziamo
giorno uno è appena cominciata dalla
sugar cial veramente me l'aspettavo più
semplice per il nuovo a me che non
mangia dolci però però ho sentito niente
pasta pasta virano quella integrale del
niente al tel
mutu che è pronto no la vasta
integrativa magnate voi tanto mi sto
bene in caffettino di solito un po di
zucchero se lo metto vedremo più avanti
che succederà per il momento il primo
pranzo io non ero pronto tanto che
stamattina stavo per andare a mangiare
latte e cereali primis ha detto no non
posso fine cereali zucchero zucchero mi
mangerò un uovo che l'unico uomo che ho
nella speranza di riuscire a farlo
perché vorrei farlo in maniera diversa
oggi vorrei farlo in camicia bisogno
nuovo in camicia da una vita non è una
compatta di cucina quindi non devo
spiegare niente a nessuno ti prego ho
creato una red bull hanno creato un
nuovo unico uovo io me lo mangio
comunque album e ho cucinato un tuorlo
ecco il mio tuorlo da solo è solo il
primo giorno ottimista positivo ecco qui
il mio pranzo un po di cortellini in
brodo waits son parmisan chase e penso
che nulla di tutto ciò abbia zucchero 1
la che delizia soprattutto le poll
intenzioni italiano nel corso della
settimana prevedo una crisi per chiudere
in bellezza una fettina di pollo senza
zuccheri ottimo food dove siamo nella
settimana zuccheri è a me fare tesoro
niente perché se con gli occhialoni
scuri viviano sola soletta tanfoglio
stavo riflettendo che successa una cosa
posso saperlo
vogliamo ha deciso che per questa
settimana dobbiamo fare la nostra car
challenge sai che vuol dire questo nome
non mangeremo zuccheri per tutta la
settimana
praticamente possono andare tipo il
truciolato leccare la polvere dagli
angoli anche c'è e basta ci posso
pensare attaccata ma tu non la trave
allucinante che poi voce di no e il
canale si chiama willwoosh per chi sta
cosa la devo far fuori io non so va beh
sì però spiegano il perché siamo dei
maiali stiamo prendendo pane cos'è
affettato rucola niente di tutto ciò si
può mangiare però abbiamo appena giocato
a calcetto di trento andata al cinema
neanche ci siamo lavati quindi saremo lì
sony della sala resteremo una sala con
il nostro sudore e fetore esatto neanche
lo state sentendo ma in realtà gianmarco
sta bussando da far schifo arrivo russa
di questa è la nostra cena mezzo panino
tornata a casa dagli allenamenti o una
fonemi di filiale quindi ho deciso di
mangiare di più ma se il pesce per
ferito non voglia di zuccheri e la cosa
particolare è che la mia energia dalla
mattina alla sera è stata identica non
ho avuto nei picchi nei sbalzi affetto
meraviglioso paese crea nuovo e cipolla
con dei fagioli in spagna il numero dei
verdi comunque noi mostra manna vedesse
il film con mezzo panino sullo stomaco
cosa noi prendiamo i biglietti e bui il
becchino
no non possiamo meglio primizio
terribile cioè ma contaminato la salsa
alla qua no è riparabile è tutta per me
stasera abbiamo sgarrato regalo non
aspetta ma per corno e lipu e magna ma
chi sia anti lo sa lo zucchero qui
stasera nava così allegri deve sapere
marine quest'anno ha fatto sicuramente
pure loro insalatine con loro
bistecchine ma non mancano affettato di
comunicati e barbe e io vi sono giorno 2
buongiorno ragazzi primo aggiornamento
di questo inizio di seconda giornata la
prima cosa che ho notato è che io non
brufoli e oggi mi sono svegliato con uno
qui faccio cielo riuscite non provvedere
e uno nell'interno della coscia
non so cosa mangiare la mattina quindi
per oggi passerò direttamente a pranzo
oggi non si sgarra
io non mangerò questa roba zuccherata
non mi di prendere mai attesi mi
smettila non mi devi prendere io mi
mangio la carne senza zucchero grazie
prosciugare challenge uno può fallire ma
non perseverare l'ho detto è errare
humanum est perseverare gli appelli dei
volti ancora ed extra diletto ma devi
essere meno timida ma non te li prendo
che sono entri in crisi c'è lo zucchero
verso giro ma penso sia l'ultimo perché
non di zuccheri di nostra mattina non è
vero
stamattina la lizza dopo lo sgarro di
ieri sera brodino caldo di pollo pollo
lesso e verdure vogliamo rapporto pranzo
ordinato avevo voglia di sushi c'è stato
già altri un problema perché mi sono
ricordo
dove all'interno del riso c'è un sacco
di zucchero che soprattutto non posso
mangiare il riso bianco perché contiene
stage che non sta c'è lui no se potevo
mangiare alla fine era il sashimi non
appena maria da casa e mi sono reso
conto che c'era un piccolo problema io
non posso mangiare la soia quindi sto
per fare una cosa secondo me abominevole
apprendo dell'olio prendo wasaby inizio
non si rischia dai sarà buono che
c'entrano
ora la soia è meglio ma nel calcio dico
io ho aggiunto un po di sale poco poco
pepe ed è a sé sco come potete ben
vedere la mia nasce per challenge sta
procedendo a gonfie vele
non bastava la mia intolleranza al
lattosio la mia tenuta intolleranza al
lattosio diciamo quindi sto facendo
merendina con uno yogurt del 1200 avanti
cristo
c'erano i crociati quando è scaduto
questo yogurt è venuto a trovarmi enrico
eri come va quindi con questa dieta alla
grande alla grande alla grande mai
l'occasione ho portato anche il cappello
con 6 scritto sopra che sa significare
la fine di questo calvario ma perché
mancano sei giorni mancano 6 giorni alla
fine
carino come sta andando alla grande soul
funk bravo bravo matri 5 e dico se n'è
andato nel frattempo ho la mia cena o 90
se questa fetta di carne per l'altra
persa e porro signori non sugar ti
ammazzo zucchero riguardo ti do un pugno
ecco rosa di walter o poco mi sta
importando zucchero quale ti faccio
cotanta piace piace zucchero zucchero il
cantante ovviamente sto per uscire a chi
non è che sono che crei dei segni però a
volte parlano chiaro indosso 6 giorni
sulla testa guardate dove lasciato i sei
giorni che indossa sulla testa enrico
beh se qualcosa più la sua motivazione
ben cena trito di cipolla uova provo a
fare con una mano ecco ci sembra un
verbo minore adesso per ora teme che
buono tra le note peperoncino fa sempre
bene
l l l l l l approdo questi crea
cassintegrati qui c'è scritto 0,0 con un
grande amico di lanciare aveva
ricorderemo forte che ho finito di
maniace una fame antiquati le sponde
clementine un milione di sapore sono
andata a casa di provini sentore ottieni
li ho la stessa età in modo dentro e
vassoi o impostare la nonna che poteva
pescare hanno mangiato ieri tempi della
stasera con voglia di zuccheri giorno 2
con un po di valderice l'auto il meno e
spero come di aver persone dei 27 kg per
credito è un embrione giorno 3 con cuore
di tutti quanti ho perso un chilo e
mezzo davvero e non lo posso sopportare
così lazio è naturale ma che non la sa
fare cosa e il terzo
[Risate]
[Applauso]
nel gruppo ci siamo detti ragazzo ho
perso un kg 81 kg e mezzo e perché io no
lotta per il momento pranzo qui mangio
una tartara che dovrà accompagnerò con
sempre altre cose che sanno di niente
improvvisamente quindi una persone che
si comportano bene io ti odio ti odio
guardami di odio ma mi sono sempre
comportato bene lo spieghiamo che
abbiamo gioco una partita a calcetto
ragazzi non mi interessa faticare un po
mangiando dai marco e quello che dice
che ogni volta mento è molto più pesante
adesso mangiamo troppo leggero mi ha
tolto la pasta di pane
mi sembra perché magni comunque quello
del ferrarese
io voglio vedere di nuovo che padre ho
capito tutto io continuerò però
continuerà al test altamente non può
fallire la tua famiglia
continuiamo a perfetta salta fratello
fratello mio vicino
zero zucchero per le garba sta facendo
questo perché diciamolo gara col dolce
mamma mi ha appena finito di mangiare
sono stato incastrato in questa cena mi
hanno costretto questo posso dire a mia
discolpa però dai alla fine o sgarlato
solo col dolce su aglianica strani
domani cercherò di fare meglio
devo dire che mi lasci car challenge va
benissimo
in realtà avevo quei molto anche giu
abbiamo ovviamente fino a quel punto di
lavorare fuori però sbagliato
giorno 4 svela con colazione a letto
grazie meno lo picchiano tidona cios
d'oro da giammarco e ne ha appena
riferito che ieri sera si è mangiato la
torta rustica e non la ripresa porta
rossi ha fatta con la pasta non la puoi
mangiare la torta rustica lo so dove c'è
richeri sera di ieri con gli aerei o
nasconditi un'osteria roma l'attestato
lo sanno tutti ma non ho mangiato
zuccheri la cheesecake eccetto la gente
che siamo pronti a fallire tutti insieme
aveva iniziato il posto di forlan che
buffone no per ragazzi e buffoni e basta
deve essere ripreso musica di questa
difesa
se posso parlare senza essere ripresa
scusa non mi riprendere abbiamo ciliare
oppure la linea sarà facendo lo schifo
come l'unica differenza che la via non
si riprende vero la linea si nutre di
tutto questo nell'ombra nell'ombra sa
vanno da che cioè la carriera ma devo
magna che ci sarà un po di pangrattato
con un passo così lo speriamo più di
lampo sono meno patito il pasto clichy
miseramente queste cose per me non
l'hanno esprimere questo è sale e un po
di me penso con la famiglia di lui
abbiamo pollo panel al cento per cento
integrale e e bettina niente regali e
andato tutto baccanti gente ne frega
niente bianca ho appena fatto un errore
ho mangiato un po di quello che mi sono
reso conto che stiamo giudicando cioè
della farinata mangiato anche adesso
andate andrò in bagno
in compenso continuo con seppioline alla
carbonara è un pochino di crudi 90 per
cento miei non ci provare hanno portato
questa roba qui soffriamo in due set la
dieta 3 senso appare l'attento giorno 5
un giorno era passati nella stata
penultimo giorno ed è tornata la
meravigliosa comodi mela e yogurt greco
al pm era stata fatta con cura contro il
muro da lui lo sa che c'è dentro perché
io sto fa la noah sugar challenge
benvenuto perfino a soqquadro messe
pasta integrale questo secondo magnar
pollo di domani ma perché lui a pura
passa qui ha voluto la pasta integrata
io sto ca e ho pensato di dare un
secondo un contorno che è meglio
buffetti nei suoi lume messo in italia
neanche quattro dalla birra mi trovo a
milano sono con luca valle di giapponesi
particolare alla fine io non posso
mangiare nulla delle cose che ci sono a
questi il salato aspetto intendo il mais
che non posso mangiarlo 11 in sala
follia
quando a fare capolino da mangiare
perché non mangiando times però appena
fatto la spesa come è stato fare la
spesa si garante dai ma devo dire quello
che ho fatto sul serio
se poi si certo senso portato a questo
punto ma nonostante la rottura no
quattro giorni incontrerò sono 4 piloti
di palla ma distruggono tutte le persone
che stanno intorno a te si ero un po
nervoso ma poi trovo in stazione e sto
tornando a roma non sapevo se mangiare
qui alla fine
ho preso questa roba qua in acqua con
tipo limone europa dentro non so perché
sento che è una cosa così 4 euro per
metterci un tumore dentro protetto dai
quadratica due di questi cosi riso
venere piselli salmone mandorle tutte
cose che posso mangiare alla modica
cifra di ribotta risolti anche questi le
104 stato depurato una cosa positiva che
in un altro tantissimo il senso di fame
io mangiavo ormai per abitudine per che
saprebbero mangiare che c'è adesso con
un vuoto quelli di maniere pure tavolo
eccoci qui
questa cena pollo con berta finocchietto
buonissimo l'ho già iniziato ovviamente
del cilli condito con cipollina non so
che altro a bacilli la usano tutti mi ha
fatto cilli lo sciroppo della tosse per
fare un po di contrasto ecco tutto
quanto zucchero feriti tengo a precisare
che è tutta roba biodegradabile anche la
forchetta e cucchiaio è tutta roba
biodegradabile plastic free ragazzi
sugarfree plastic free
eccoci eccetto questo vabbè che traffico
però perfeziona comunicano il giorno 6
con gli amici questo quiete uno in
camicia che ho cercato di fare a
mostruoso e lì ce n'è un altro ma che i
ragazzi fa che purtroppo ovviamente
zuccheri fine da nove la settimana come
fate voi per la vita marmi dove si può
bere dai marinai usa tv amici thomas e
raffaele che hanno preparato apposta un
pasto lo sugar che tu hai appena
definito abbonata col tonno nemmeno la
carne è questa buffonata però intanto
grazie alla fibra il b b starò mai
thomas ha prima portato poi un giorno no
non lo dico io lo trovo questa
fantastica crostata di ricotta e
pistacchio è proprio la serata sbagliata
ha dovuto fingere che io dovessi fare
delle analisi del sangue per salvarvi
una mamma guarda qui purtroppo rifare
della crisi per la glicemia medico la
scrivano può mangiare zucche mama nera
vergine mia del mondo cosa prende a
rituali qualcosa senza zuccheri ti
voglio vedere
tutto perfettamente senza zucchero sto
mangiando ho detto per me delle patatine
fritte da mettere in mezzo le patenti se
non mangi le salse fase cosi guglielmo
secondo me sicuramente fatto tutto bene
la patatina vita non ti cambierà niente
[Risate]
ma cosa sta venendo vino non puoi non è
anche giorno 7 mi sono dimenticato di
filmare il pranzo ho fatto fagioli e
tonno con due fette di pane di segale
ultimo giorno finalmente consentito al
bilancio e sono riferito di un chilo e
anche vero che non vado in bagno da un
po di tempo mese o non è riducibile
quest'anno la tedesca il sì sto meglio
ci possa fare anche se non vederla in
realtà non vedo l'ora di assaggiare la
mia prima cosa dolce dopo una settimana
in cui veramente non mi ha toccata mezza
per una lettera mi sveglia prima cosa
che faccio lanciarmi e ultimo giorno di
questa challenge ammetto io ho fatto
mezzo come cabaret e quindi anche oggi
se magna dai e ora vedrete chi sta per
arrivare
eccolo hemyar e quanto nella roma guarda
la trave nel tuo più nulla
gli altri vabbè dai al nostro car
challenge è andata a farsi [ __ ]
smartphone che belli non abbiamo fatto
bene ma che bello che sono pertanto
visto che questo non è stato fatto sei
mangiare pure te dove dovete le prove di
cosa ne pensi della sugar challenge
bene o male proprio male si pensi della
show car challenge è stato sconvolto dal
cibo da quello che ho visto mangiare
arrivo questa sera per cappato le
riprese giammarco ma non vi credete che
questo film siamo spigole santo ed è
mangiato la valle è mai stato così con
tanto di fare un pasto sono tornato agli
allenamenti questa qui è la mia ultima
cena della stiva non ho mai sgarrato
struttura per la raffinata e la perna
dell con la guerra ferrarelli certo ma
che cos'è la pasta integrale con
zuccheri rispetto di essa pure perfino
devo dire giorno 8 ce l'abbiamo fatta
una settimana intera passata senza
zucchero senza farine raffinate senza
alcol e finalmente dato conto di farlo
l'assaggio non ci posso credere
sentiamo quale si voterà felicità che ho
quasi paura a farlo non che abbia paura
che da un momento così su questa vetta
quando considerazioni finali della
settimana non è stata così terribile
quanto pensassi è un percorso di salute
tops che presento più sgonfio
ho perso la tv il mezzo e soprattutto
regione sentito più energico ancora non
so se questo risultato è dovuto al fatto
che ho fatto settimana in un visite
avere avuto più problemi problemi più
grandi sono qui
per me sta più mentali legati alla
voglia dello zucchero la voglia di la
coccola diverse ma cercherò di andare
avanti non taglierò tutti gli zuccheri
aggiunti maceroni mangiare un profilo
più che pulito e basta veramente la fine
di questo in terminal dire video nel
prossimo episodio il terrore di aver
fatto una cazzata ma una cazzata
aiutatemi a dire cazzate a chiamarmi
scemo